livres de cuisine bandes dessinées
mangas ou encore prix goncourt il y en a
pour tous les goûts
en ce 24 décembre sillonnant les allées
à la recherche du livre au parfait les
retardataires se presse avant de fêter
le réveillon
je fus à la recherche d'un roman
historique qu'elle a pas lu mais comme
je suis pas tellement au fait de idée de
ce qu'est la luz qu'elle a pas lui donc
je suis un peu perplexe
c'est vraiment les derniers achats donc
effectivement je pense que je suis un
peu comme beaucoup de monde au dernier
moment j'ai pas eu le temps de boucler
mes cadeaux donc j'ai des petits cadeaux
de dernière minute à faire ce matin donc
c'est un petit peu la course le livre un
cadeau incontournable qui sera au pied
du sapin demain matin la librairie du
pavé du canal s'est préparé au rush des
cadeaux de dernière minute
il ya beaucoup de monde encore
aujourd'hui contrairement à ce qu'on
pourrait penser tout le monde a passé
ses cadeaux de noël
donc les gens sont plutôt exigeant donc
on essaye de répondre au mieux à leurs
attentes et leur proposer le meilleur
service possible juste que jusqu'à ce
soir 18 heures du côté des jouets la
reine des neiges
harry potter et star wars sont les
cadeaux phare de ce noël 2010 neuf dans
cette enseigne de jouets à rambouillet
certains sont en quête des derniers
cadeaux en espérant qu'ils seront
toujours en rayon je suis venu chercher
un jouet un barbie licorne
j'ai écumé 3 4 magasins dans la région
pour là j'ai pas trouvé
je n'ai pas pris le temps de venir
chercher des cadeaux avant et je trouve
ça quand même important d'offrir des
cadeaux donc j'ai quand même j'avais
beaucoup de choses à faire et donc
voilà donc à de nouvelles idées qui
arrive donc je viens je viens prendre
pour compléter on va dire depuis
novembre le magasin accueille tous les
jours ses clients mais aujourd'hui
chacun veut finir sa liste de cadeaux
destinés au père noël
on a eu énormément de clients donc notre
travail
c'était de bien les recevoir et surtout
leur trouver des produits qu'il
souhaitait et d'avoir les bons produits
avec un magasin plein et puis d'être à
leur écoute pour leur trouver tout ce
qui leur manque là sur la dernière ligne
droite
et même si ces cadeaux sont achetés à la
dernière minute ils seront tout de même
apprécié demain matin sous le sapin